>> DEMOCRATS ABOUT TO PAY A
HEAVY PRICE FOR THEIR LOVE
AFFAIR WITH LOCAL POLITICS.
FORMER PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG SENDING THEM
THIS WARNING COME UP THE PARTY
IS LOOKING AT A WIPEOUT UP AND
DOWN THE BALLOT.
THE PRESIDENT'S AWFUL NUMBERS
NOT MAKING THE SITUATION ANY
BETTER.
I'M TOLD WE ARE SHORT ON TIME,
SO WE WILL GO AROUND THE TABLE
ON AN OVERALL REACTION FOR THE
QUESTION I SINCERELY HAVE IS,
WHAT WITH THE MESSAGE BE OF
DEMOCRATS IN THE MIDTERM?
WHAT YOU TAKING TO THE VOTERS?
>> Dana: IF I WERE TO HAVE ANY
DEMOCRAT TO COME ON THE SHOW, I
WOULD SAY JOE BIDEN AND THE
ANSWER IS GOING TO BE A WELCOME
NO, I THINK HE'S VERY BUSY AND
HE UNITS US TO FOCUS ON THAT.
THE EASIEST GIG IN WASHINGTON
HAS BEEN A DEMOCRATIC CONSULTANT
BECAUSE THE MEDIA DOES ALL YOUR
WORK FOR YOU.
AT THIS POINT, THEY ARE STARTING
TO FIND OUT OH, WAIT, THEY ARE
SCRAPING THE BOTTOM OF THE
BARREL PAIR THEY DON'T HAVE A
BUGGY MAN TO RUN, PSYCHIC
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG IS SHAPING UP
TO BE A YEAR -- VERY GOOD FOR
REPUBLICANS BUT I THINK
REPUBLICANS ARE EVEN GOING TO
WIN THE SENATE RACE IN VERMONT.
>> Jesse: HOW MUCH DO THEY
MISS DONALD TRUMP RIGHT NOW?
OH, THEY MISS THEM FOR THEY ARE
TRYING TO REHAB HIM.
BUT HE WILL JUST GOLF.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY TRIED TO MAKE HIM THE
BOGEYMAN, BUT IT MADE DeSANTIS
LOOK BETTER AND EVERYBODY WENT
AND VACATIONED IN FLORIDA.
AND McCARTHY DOESN'T REALLY
SHOW ENOUGH LEG TO GET ANYBODY
REALLY AFTER HIM.
AND McCONNELL IS JUST SO
McCONNELL THAT THERE'S REALLY
NO WHERE TO LAND THE GLOVE.
SO IT IS EITHER TUCKER OR PUTIN
AS THE BACKUP.
[LAUGHTER]
AND BIDEN DOESN'T WANT TO NAME
JACK TUCKER AND IF PUTIN ONLY
WORKS IF YOU CAN TIE HIM TO
TRUMP, BUT THAT IS NOT WORKING.
SO THEY ARE OUT OF FOILS.
>> INDEED WE DO.
GERALDO, WHAT BLOOMBERG POINTS
OUT IS A SIMPLE THING THAT WE
ALL KNOW, BUT THEY'RE JUST
REALIZING ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE, THAT WHEN YOU'RE
SPENDING TIME RENAMING SCHOOLS
INSTEAD OF OPENING THEM, IT'S
GOING TO BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
>> EVERYBODY KNOWS HOW STUPID
THAT WAS.
>> BUT THEY DID IT!
>> THEY WILL NEVER GET STRONGER
THAN THEY WERE THE DAY BEFORE.
BUT I WANT TO SAY HOW DEMOCRATS
HAVE NOT GOTTEN ANY ATTENTION TO
LATINOS.
THAT, NUMERICALLY SPEAKING, IT'S
GOING TO BE THE BIG GAP ON THE
LIBERAL LEFT.
BUT BY IGNORING LATINOS, THEY
ALREADY ARE -- WHAT IS IT?
46 G.O.P., 45 DEMOCRATS.
THE GROUP TAKEN FOR GRANTED BY
DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES, REAGAN
WAS RIGHT, THE REPUBLICANS DID
NOT KNOW IT YET, BUT THEY WERE
REPUBLICANS.
>> Dana: I WILL JUST SAY WHEN
YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO EAT AS A
MIDDLE-CLASS FAMILY BECAUSE YOUR
GROCERY STORE BILL HAS DOUBLED
IN A YEAR, THAT UNDERPINS EVERY
SINGLE ISSUE.
AND WHEN YOU CAN'T FILL UP YOUR
GAS TANK TO GO TO WORK, PEOPLE
PAY ATTENTION TO THAT,
ESPECIALLY FROM A PRESIDENT WHO
PROMISED NOT TO RAISE TAXES ON
ANYBODY LESS THAN $400,000 A
YEAR.
INFLATION IS THE BOTTO